in winds of up to 75 miles per hour
clouds of red sand from the Sahara
Desert is causing chaos in the northern
Canaries leaving hundreds of British
holiday makers stranded on the island
the government has declared a state of
alert as a dust storm which turned the
sky orange has reduced visibility all
flights in and out of Gran Canaria
Airport antenna we've have been
suspended but Marty O'Neill managed to
get off the island on one of the last
flight back to the UK on Saturday it was
quite eerie Lerner looking in places and
I very quickly descended under this red
grip you could feel in your skin in your
teeth you can even feel it in your mouth
and your nose we were one of the last
flights right we met people on the way
home that actually got their flight
turned back and couldn't land the
airports were closing the board was
doing where we were extremely lucky to
get home the Canaries which our popular
tourist destination is now choking in
dust people still on the island
have been advised to stay indoors and
keep their windows and doors shut it's
never been as bad as this for about 10
years or more people who live out here
all the time say it's a very severe
Colima and it's been very very hot an
incredibly dusty so why is this
happening the sandstorms known as the
Kalima regularly affects the holiday
island
it occurs when strong winds bring hot
dry air filled with dust officials are
warning residents to stay off the
streets because of the dust and sand and
as temperatures rise so does the risk of
fires on the island the good news is
though that they do tend to pass quite
quickly so that you know if the
disruption that we're seeing at the
moment with the flights it should pass
and people should be able to get back
from half-turn
a picture-perfect holiday for many has
now turned into a nightmare ordeal and
forecasters fear their worst is yet to
come
no Philips Sky News